[Music]
one boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Saki and
today we have the pleasure of sitting
down with the two founders of next big
thing Courtney Thomas Dharam Wilson
thank you for joining us that was insane
thank you so what's up very much it's
been a little while since we've seen
each other I'm glad that you're finally
on the show shows now same location
where you are doing your live series as
well yes exactly it's a good location
piano fights good place so you guys have
done 24 of these episodes where you're
highlighting spotlighting Millennials of
color across tech media politics
entrepreneurship why do you guys have
the fire under your ass to do this go
for it I always knew that black women
Darla and me like tarred me the ability
to make things cool we know how to make
things popular because we now truly are
that and I always get into a point here
I think it's cool
to really celebrate that every day
heroes the ones that are working the
nine-to-five really it's like an eight
to seven type situation commutes with
the commute if you counted I love
celebrating entrepreneurship because
everyone that's what everyone that's
what every business is it started with a
single person having a
a team together everyone Disney was a
start-up at one point so yeah just to
really funnel that idea of the things
that I think are cool let's turn it into
let's highlight it let's make it what we
believe it to be and we did that yeah I
think when it started we were on another
web series a friend of ours had a series
a short series called bottomless and we
sat around drinking mimosas and talking
about things and after that Kourtney and
I were like what if this was like sit
around and like talk about things yeah
and then we got together to try to
figure out like what a project would
look like we're like we could do things
with all these different people because
we know so many cool people doing so
many awesome things and then it was like
that's the idea and I think to
Kourtney's point like we really do have
a good eye for what is who is going to
be the next big thing like we tap people
and then they they ascend
[Laughter]
one of our first spreadsheets we ever
made it's a list of everyone that we
just knew personally or knew of in some
way and we said these are the people
that we would want on our show yeah so
many people have literally won awards
now they are so shot off into the
stratosphere and we were like yeah good
problems - yeah exactly we essentially
have like the list of people who are
about to blow up because they all do
before we can get our hands on them
right some of them we do capture just in
time yes so yeah a lot of them yeah very
similar in that sense we also bring on
people that are kind of ascending
through these tech media
inertia politics and yeah trying to
impact the world in a good way we want
to highlight and amplify their voices
get more people inspired about that
seems like you're doing the exact same
thing why your Millennials of colors
specifically as a focus and really
there's much need for this in the world
because there's not enough of it right
where are the Arabic women of color
where are the Asian women and of course
where are these groups of people
springing up in media shows highlighting
people in their cultures that are
crushing it and that's why you know your
re are there even other ones like you
right now out there there but it's hard
to say that they're doing exactly what
actually think there is there are people
I mean obviously there are plenty of
like new media organizations that are
focused on black people or people of
color or women or what-have-you
I don't think there's anybody
specifically at least from what I've
seen I don't I haven't seen anybody else
who specifically dedicated to
highlighting like up-and-comers
like people in that specific spot yeah I
could see that because I definitely see
shows that want to focus on Millennials
and they definitely want to draw
Millennials and I see people that
obviously focus on like African American
lifestyle black culture or any very
specific culture but Durand I remember
this a three-hour conversation that we
had we were first ironing on our brand
and we were trying to decide should we
just focus this on black people or is it
just any millennial of color and then
what was that conversation like it was
hard it was a hard conversation cuz
we're very strong individuals who
believed so strongly and both of our
ideas and we were both right like there
was no wrong answer and we still end up
in a place I think we just like let it
happen naturally we let our biases just
live
hello we do have conversations though
like I think you kind of had to talk me
off the ledge because I was like there's
only black people on this show what do
we do oh it's men and women we were
talking about men and women and like
LGBT representation yeah yeah like as we
should be more cognizant of those things
those are conversations that we have
very often like we just are just brought
this up she was like loving it
everyone's doing a great job like where
are people with disabilities where are
LGBTQ people where are trans people like
where are these people and I'm like
you're right you're right like yeah
we're just focusing on these like
able-bodied like young black sometimes
almost like majority light-skinned black
people and we have to pay attention to
that because if we're trying to be the
difference then we have to actively
fight against the default and it's so
easy
yeah that's such a good way to put it
you want to be the difference you have
fight against the default that's good
and it's like being the black sheep in
this case with all the white sheep
groaning around going in one direction
how can you be different going in this
other direction and what is that it look
like how can you inspire other people to
follow a similar path and so okay so now
now that you're you know you you picked
you've picked Millennials of color in
general and now you're trying to also
diversify neurodiversity all these other
kind of aspects so so I guess the you've
been now 24 episodes in your doing live
shows out of these conversations that
you've had hi spotlighting the country
are you are you mostly sitting down with
the with the people and you're talking
them about what they're building how
they're building it why that's important
it's usually the conversation and then
your playful you know you're joking
around yeah yeah the shows great links
in the bio of course you guys all know
the bottom and okay and so then out of
these 24 episodes who have been you know
some of these guests that you featured
that have been ones that have really
really made an impact on you and on the
audience and and why did they
make that impact do you think right I
just wanted one more thing everyone does
tell us about what they're working on
and definitely what inspires them and we
have fun with them but the thing that we
get all of our guests to talk about is
their struggle in their journey a lot of
times let's talk about that Millennials
get we we are either used or abused by
the media either they love us and we
just popped up out of nowhere like roses
from concrete and we are famous at 17 we
weigh a hundred and ten pounds and we
are this being a perfection that no one
birth we just popped onto planet Earth
or we're ruining the economy we're
taking several businesses out with us
the diamond industry is struggling
because we're struggling come on see the
connection yes so we're not buying
houses because we're eating avocado
toast all these things mortgage and yeah
so we wanted to focus on these
individuals want to get them before the
media warps their story until you'll
never be this this is how amazing they
are we want to just you know bring that
back down to ground level have these
one-on-one conversations and hopefully
the realness of that struggle is
inspiring because I don't think anybody
necessarily comes on recommends their
path it's full of rocks and if we're
being honest I don't even recommend like
my path and but you know if you find
your if you find yourself on it here's
one way that one person navigated it and
came out the other side I also like I
think it was some of the conversation we
have with Amber what do you do while
you're waiting yes what you do when
you're waiting for the big break to come
and I also like people being really
honest about times in their lives where
they were fortunate yeah I think people
talk and and lionize hard work as if
it's this magical thing that's just
gonna make sure that you have success in
your life and that's can we curse on
here of course that's [ __ ] Thanks
that's not accurate
or any literally anybody story it's not
ever just I pulled myself up by my
bootstraps and he right now
nobody stories nobody started I don't
know what American dream tale you've
heard like amber had a friend who was a
singer she's also a singer she's went
out on maternity leave
and that's how amber who was on she was
in the cast of Hamilton that just came
to San Francisco yeah she got that job
because her friend she got a job as a
backup singer for Lauryn Hill because
her friend was like hey take this job so
you don't steal my spot when I come back
from having this child essentially and
she got to tour Europe with Lauryn Hill
which is a huge and massive opportunity
there is a level of being ready for your
opportunities when they come like some
the preparation and the hard work helps
with that part yeah but at the end of
the day she was blessed with a
stunningly gorgeous voice and she knew
the right person at the right time right
and it doesn't mean that she didn't
deserve the opportunity that she got but
like those little sparks of things that
propel you forward I think are important
to tell people because or else it just
seems like what am i doing I'm like and
I'm not making any progress yeah that's
that hopelessness that we're not here
for I think that's easy to fall into
especially as Millennials age and we get
older and we realize that not all of our
dreams came true the way that everyone
wanted them to so to cut down on some of
that yeah demystify it a little bit yes
that is so much to unpack anything right
there I love it okay so we started out
with this what is going on with the
media and how is it affecting young kids
that are up and coming and so there's
this you either become this rose on the
sidewalk spout it from nothing dropped
on this earth you're perfect yea the
followers whatever this is crazy I'm
constantly analyzing la culture and like
their Instagram life is just not
supposed to do yeah it's just just even
just peeking into like the stories and
like the all that madness and the
conspicuous consumption lifestyle is
just it's crazy to me it's just
absolutely nuts but there's that or or
there is this other side of things which
is I think this one's kind of nuts is
this young people that are the have
something that they're trying to build
into the world or push every single day
that they're trying to build and then
maybe by the time they're 30
they haven't seen the fruits of their
labor yet and this is continuously
happening more and more through through
people's 20s and and it's not just about
just you know just tying your shoes up
tight and just going and hustling every
single day there's this stroke of luck
these strokes of good fortune that come
with this process and it's really good
that you're starting that we're really
unpacking this because that's that's
crucial a lot of what a lot of success
in life now is who you know oh and by by
surrounding yourself with really smart
people that are building the future in
different ways you'll get plucked into
different groups and given different
opportunities at these times that are
just seem to be perfect and then to have
the humility to say that I'm nothing I'm
nothing and I'm I'm also something it's
a paradox but then there's also the
teams of people that we work with that
and help make it true yeah I think for
my part and my my parents hate when I
say this but like nothing about me is
exceptional everything about nearly
everything about what I have achieved
thus far in life should be totally
expected given that I grew up in a
household with two parents who are
college educated and had advanced
degrees and had their own business same
like like yeah I Pratt but I should have
done it yeah and that was like I had all
the resources to be able to do that I
had like SAT classes and things that
other people don't have so yeah I mean
they're like dude or you were tired of
like I didn't have to work as hard as
some people do though yeah right like I
didn't have to go to school hungry I
didn't have like I didn't have food
insecurity I didn't have yeah like you
know it's disability like I yeah yeah
correct nutrient deficiency for the
brain
exactly a kid knowing where your next
meal is coming from like you don't want
to do your math homework you want to
figure out how you're gonna eat that's
not fair that's fair yeah it's so true
opportunity baguettes more opportunity
and when someone sits there and denies
that one opportunity that they may have
had access to easier than others that
didn't lead to what can happen is a
snowball effect truly I feel like next
big thing is living in a snowball effect
right now like people are hearing about
us and opportunities are coming just one
after the other but they're all coming
from this one source so in same thing is
like we are paralleling the journey that
we talked about other people having
which is like now people are like oh hey
like do you want to look at these
t-shirts and maybe we could have like
people are just like oh you have this
thing and it's great and it's just
always been that and it's like we've
been doing this for years Darwin the
first time when we were talking about it
was like this may not be an overnight
deborah cross courtney this may take
like seven years yeah reference
superfruit which is another youtube
channel that's blown up of course but it
took years yeah so to even do you be
doing what we're doing at that
three-year mark I'm amazed personally I
didn't expect any of this and it is
weird like when you do keep going but
and something just hits at a certain age
it's 30 maybe it's 32 maybe it's 40 yeah
I think we gotta get past the idea of I
hate to say it but like baby boomers put
these like labels on these ages of what
you're supposed to have accomplished and
it's just not true and it's really
unhealthy yeah I think about it as a 30
year old look like I'm single what I
don't marry until I'm like 36 does that
mean that my wife up until 36 was
meaningless absolutely not and I would
hear I would hate to think that I'm not
spending some of my best years and
enjoying them fully because of some
expectation some outdated expectation
one that's still not serving anybody
well I am its
the economy is literally not set up for
you to do those things so like to have
zero children yeah not buy diapers wait
like I'm trying to pay my rent yeah can
you imagine taking care of a human and
trying to pit like that's bonkers to me
that's a disaster in the making and
that's what so many people around the
world that should that fall into poverty
that is the reason why is an early child
and like you said opportunity begets
other opportunities if you're not given
opportunity in the first place
oh man I let's let's unpack this a
little bit more because I think I think
this I think this is becoming a constant
theme I was just at the Berkeley College
Republicans event and I went there
because Dave Rubin Charlie Kirk and
Candace Owens were there and I was there
so let's let's unpack this impact so so
I went there to challenge them because I
didn't think that enough people were
challenging them in an analytical and
emotionally intelligent way to where it
was really resonating with them yet and
I hadn't really seen them take a stage
with people that challenged them yeah
most of the time they're taking stages
in echo chambers and and they're worse
true across the board in many of the
right are on the on the left this isn't
ya know nothing to do with identity
politics let's drop by done epochs
completely out of the equation and just
talk about the strict the conversation
that that's occurring in that in that
location
it's not very open-minded it's not very
nuanced or multivariate it's very binary
and it's also not very economist it's
very agitated of aggressive and so I was
there and I them and we posted the video
on our channel and of the question that
that I asked and it was about having
more
multivariate nuance to quantum is
open-minded conversation of what they
could do to do that more and so my
reason why I'm bringing this up is
because as we unpack the importance of
of people being able to actually have
conversations across the political
spectrum or be like hey 18 year-olds
have a little bit too much pressure on
their shoulders to hit a million
Instagram followers there's that you can
be successful when you're 40 in whatever
way the successful means to you there's
all these different ways and this whole
notion of kind of those three a lot of
what they were mentioning at the time
was that you know you're the author of
your life be yourself [ __ ] go fight go
hustle we don't they don't really talk
that much about opportunity and the
importance of giving more people
opportunity it's almost like there's a
disconnect between a lot of people that
are speaking on those stages and the
actual communities of people that lack
opportunity because if they were there
observing what lacked opportunity means
then it might resonate a little bit more
and so I think it's just really
important to figure out how to how to
bridge that fat cap in that conversation
I agree I just I gotta tell ya but the
names that you just named I'm not sure
if that's the goal I think it is to be
at like to agitate and to get people
riled up in a very emotional place
that's not intelligent and I don't know
like we can talk about it but with
attitudes like that with words that hurt
more than they help and see the state of
things around us like you just can't
deny that no one's sitting in a good
place in America 2018 like no one's
skipping down the street and like live
in their best lives I'm sorry even if
your tax returns turned out good
you are not sitting there living your
best life I know that for a fact so like
I think it's I want to add a question
like how much energy is worth investing
in people who are committed to
advocating and not solving so this is
that's what I was gonna ask something
similar because I think I don't know how
I feel about it like you as a white guy
going up I I think I think I think I
think that like that's a good thing
because we're busy like living in a
probe oppression and I personally like
if I look at how I spend my energy
that's not gonna be on the top of my
list going out to a Republican function
to make sure that they hear my
perspective as a black woman it's not on
the list of things to do I'm trying to
get them to sit on the show so that we
can have that conversation
yeah and and if if it does happen I
think it could change the tides of that
polarization that's occurring and so I
want to get to that free-thinking middle
ground with people that and again not
identity politics but just free thinking
middle ground and I hear what you're
saying to not prioritize going and
talking to people that are absolutely in
this other realm of thought that might
be agitated and stuff but at the same
time they're interestingly enough are
aspects of what was said in that room
that are very important so interesting
life like we can't just say that nothing
that was said in that function is good
because it's not true
there were actually good things said in
that room as well but there were also
things that were said that were I I
thought not exactly for we're thinking
in many ways and so I'm enjoying
bringing this up with you because I
actually in our sit down Jordan Peterson
talking about this whole competence
hierarchy and how people that achieve
more competence in the world end up
gaining more economic reward from that
world and then I asked him about what
holds people back from climbing up that
what are these factors these these
classes UM's factors racism isms all
these isms what are these things that
hold people back and it was very clear
that they are not ready to have that
conversation because it's so clear
what's holding people back I mean we've
been marching and protesting and asking
for clean drinking water jobs education
lack of brutality all those things those
are that's it and that's a hard
conversation to have when you're
complicit and the systems that keep
those things turning keep it going
that's what yeah I think you're right
and I think it's way more comfortable to
live and like again this is why I get
back to like the myth of hard work and
if if you put if you are living in this
capitalistic system and truly believe
that with hard work you can do anything
that means that people who have less
than can be blamed for their poverty and
the second that you throw that myth away
and uncover the fact that people have
been given different kinds of
opportunities based on who they are and
where they were born then it throws
everything else into question and I
think that level of just bringing
confusion to the worldview is
overwhelming it makes you fall into
question every single day that you talk
about our privileges as black women like
we all have privileges if we're if
you're if you can hear me and you have
access to the Internet and to a screen
you have a privilege that others don't
if you can read that is a privilege if
you know where your next meal is
coming from those are privileges so when
we I'd love to have the conversation
that basic so that we can have a
conversation about a college education
that's usually where you start to get a
little pushback from people I remember
high school debate permit of action call
high school was mostly wives a nickname
she's college prep loop and it went up
there and said you know affirmative
action what it does is takes away our
slots and it was a young white man who
was able to come to her and say see the
thing we're trying to get you to
understand is that was never just your
slot everybody has equal rights to it
and it doesn't automatically belong to
you young woman who's coming up in Marin
County like it's just it that's that's a
hard thing to bear so then when you talk
about jobs and all the things that
people do put work into but don't
realize that it is their privilege to
have that access to that work a job is
privilege in that crazy like we in
America don't really like to work that
much but realistically that's all we got
but what if there is a place where
there's no jobs available and you want
to work and you want to feed your family
and you yeah do it like in Nigeria right
now it's the four out of every ten
people are unemployed or underemployed
right now and that's a massive stat
that's a lot of people and that's not
for an extent want to work it's there's
not an opportunity there's no way around
with there is nothing there like and
they really want to work they want to do
something imagine if Amazon announced
they were gonna open up a headquarters
in Nigeria I'm sure we would see a
village and a community built up around
that because there's a job now that
we're all you bother now as well it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be done for
us and I think hate and I think it's
really important to know and it will
come in Africa soon though because
they're the next ones for toothbrushes
toothpaste underwear socks the next one
for that's like a full that's a whole
other conversation but yeah it's
I mean it's it's really about that
globalization thing that you're always
talking about that globalization thing
we all want the same things we all have
the same needs we just have different
access to opportunities and wealth yeah
so we we were unpacking now we're
unpacking opportunity more I love this I
love unpacking opportunity because it
seems as though that is this key to the
equation for every single person what
are the opportunities that they have as
they're growing up and what hope
potentially holds them back from gaining
those opportunities raising getting
raised in a household that has one
parent or being in a household where the
parent makes less than $20,000 a year
these these in the US and so I like how
you break it down by meal I think meal
is something that's very relatable for
entrepreneurs you don't know where the
next meals coming yeah yeah literally
yeah I it's funny because I think what
we're circling around is like what are
what's the reason that people so
vehemently fight against their own best
interest mmm like when you go into a
room like that and there are people in
the world who are struggling and are
voting for people who are giving tax
cuts to banks like that's the reality
right you're you're assuring in an era
of your own economic despite the my's
you know it sounds because socially
wrapped up because as long as there's
somebody else that's lower than you
you're like doing okay right this is
like there was a time a very short time
where like poor white people and black
people were like fighting on the same
lines and then how do you drive a wedge
in there right you inflate the racism
because then you can say it doesn't
matter how poor I am at least I'm not
black and then all of your
decision-making is based off of that
paradigm which means like you should be
voting with the black people we want all
the economic like we we want all the
programs that are
to help you succeed more than they even
help us exceed like you talk about
affirmative action affirmative action
helps white women more than it helps
black people on the whole I think that's
something ultimately trendy about the
privileges and the supremacy and the
racism cuz I see it happen even in my
own life like I know friends that have
voted for Trump but I'm like you're
literally sitting across from me like I
am like target number one for the Trump
administration I'm loud I'm black I'm a
woman I've had an abortion like what
else do you want from me and like I
don't know like I just think about other
circumstances like institutions that
I've been in and like I don't know if I
told you but I just found out my
graduate school is in fact going through
a lawsuit for racism and this is the
face of me being shot right it's not a
surprising fact the only thing rising is
who I'm hearing is bringing the suit
because there was a time where he wasn't
fighting so vehemently and it was kind
of I remember seeing this faculty member
like being in good with the very same
people that he's now accusing of this
racism but it's it's it's as fleeting as
favor and it's a system that was never
designed for anyone to actually win
racism does not actually believe that
white people are better racism believes
that white people believe that they are
better and more privileged and deserving
of whatever whatever it is that day
whether it's the bosses favor whether
it's being talked to you nicely whether
it's getting customer service at the
store it's wherever you are that day and
usually whenever somebody finds
themselves on the opposite side which
you will because it's a tricky system
it's not right it's like especially when
doing stand-up in Oakland on the day
you're racist compadres may not find you
to be what they're going for that let's
do an example so the opposite example is
when you go into a culture outside of
the United States or even in the United
States for that matter so you're a white
person you go to Asia and you're in Asia
no I'm talking about oh yeah sure
I want to just tie people into the exact
opposite side of the of the thinking so
that way people are like oh it's not
just all of this thought because it
because it that's this is a major part
of it yeah this this same sort of
thinking occurs in this opposite part of
the world where maybe somebody in Latin
America or Africa or Europe is visiting
Asia and then when you get to Asia you
realize that oh people are actually
treating me differently because I that
that kind of a thing yeah and then and
then and then when you visit South
America or if you visit Africa or
wherever you need to discuss the world
that changes and so this is a very
dynamic thing this is yeah and so I love
bringing up this dynamicism within
people and culture and these are these
unconscious biases that we have towards
one another across the world in these
different settings and how it changes
and so it's different even from San
Francisco to Oakland and we're right
next to each other right and so all
right so now now that we made that
example so as we come back to this idea
of like opportunity in this idea of like
climbing up and these things that hold
us back along the way if we're if we're
not able to openly talk to people across
the political spectrum about what's
going on as people try and climb up and
make impact in the world and what is
potentially holding them back or what
even unconsciously is occurring that's
holding people back then it's it's not
just like everybody is saying now
especially conservative people are
saying or classic liberal people are
saying now which is that it's all about
you you have every opportunity or in the
US example you can totally yeah you're
living in the well it's it's it's
important to balance these things out
because as much as that is true that
2018 and being in the u.s. it's a good
good place to be in the world better
than any other year in the past but at
the same time there are still these
things that hold us pills are holding
people back and that's why I find myself
as a free thinker because I really care
a lot about unpacking this conversation
and figuring out how to help maximize
especially the potential of children
that are five years old ten years old
twelve years old that are really trying
to get in to find their
potential and to not be squashed and to
not have people turn them down along the
way but actually you bring them up so so
this is really exciting to unpack with
you and I and I'm really happy that we
ended up venturing into this because I
feel like you two represent a movement
for people to care more about
Millennials of color across these
impactful industries and highlighting
them spotlighting them that's and that's
why I vibe that's so much why you did
pick anybody on the show that's why you
picked Millennials of color that's why
you picked that because that that is so
important to you to make sure that it
gets louder in the world right and we
could have a more nuanced conversation
because usually when we're reading
articles about Millennials we're pretty
sure they're only talking about white
millenials
you're talking about their own kids this
is the reality
like if a writer is like I'm angry with
my son he lives in my basement and I'm
gonna write a pinion piece in the New
York Times and blame all of them there's
not talking about they're not talking
about Joe Biden has come out and talked
about like Millennials I don't even like
hear them they're not serious just at
the clouds and told everybody to get off
his lawn it's great what about that
millennial of color whether they've been
tackling racism since 9/11 or what if
they're just like walking out on the
street and experiencing the police
brutality you don't want to hear from
that person in terms of what
technological advancement they're
working on what app they're building
like how they made it to school you
don't want to hear about their student
loan debt so that you can potentially
take that risk off like you can take
that away from them right you don't want
to hear that story
then why are you talking at all if you
only want to hear from
talk about that make that clear but
don't don't bring us all into the fold
for your own game because it's not
working it's just not working every time
I see one of those articles I post it on
our Twitter and I'm like so just do you
know like your facts are rock here and
this is why so just let us know if you
want to talk about it further
it's I think I mean just like everything
else the conversation is so much more
interesting when you acknowledge the
diversity and there's diversity and
Millennials just like there's diversity
everywhere else just like there's
diversity inside Millennials of color
like there's all kinds of groups that
are underrepresented and I mean Courtney
and I love hearing ourselves talk it's
so this is like a nicer way of doing
that than just being like hello and
listen to what I have to say because we
would be doing this anyway whether or
not we had this show right this is nice
we have a platform in which to funnel
all of this I literally like you could
just roll the camera in in front of me
at any time and I'm just talking talking
to the hook on these things and I'm just
like we need to just be recording this
at this point cause it ends up in these
like conversations at large and I'm like
who needs to hear this yeah or at least
put it out there for digital consumption
at some point and a digital record as
well of the moment and moments and time
that you had together exactly I I'm just
I just can't I can't reiterate how
important it is to be able to sit down
and have these more multivariate
discussions unpacking layers of thought
not just binary one way or the other way
because that's that's gravity and I
mention that in this video in this when
I was challenging them at Berkeley is
that that's that's something like
gravity that's like the molecular
composition of water those are very
objective binary things there and to say
that with immigration or with the
diversity or healthcare that it can be
binary you have a trillion layer onion
that you're trying to say is just
apparently binary now yeah
my science classes the people that
you're referring to have taken them
honestly okay so I have I will sighs
well that's interesting I will engage in
these free thinking conversations but
I'm pretty cut-and-dry in terms of what
I think we should be doing to move
forward tonight next I want to hear the
first session plan dar has heard it
before I'm at the point now where I am
her I'm actively encouraging
California's politicians to just pack it
in and let secede from the union and
here's why
here's why here's what I see I has this
on a watch list but the only reason
because there are some conversations
that we really have moved past like
black people are humans brown people in
general are humans those are
conversations in some parts of this
country where there's it's still up for
debate question mark even if you have a
job where your job is to service someone
and that happened to be of color people
leave it up to their own minds if
they're gonna give them a service that
day or not we have more fish to fry
we're over here trying to figure out how
we're gonna get these homeless people up
off the street without simply displacing
them we want to heal them from their
mental illness and their drug addiction
like that's a conversation that has to
be unpacked because we have people that
we need to consider I don't have time to
sit here and debate with you whether or
not I'm gonna go get this abortion when
I just got accepted to graduate school
at a top-five university we're not I'm
not having that conversation and it goes
back to that thing about energy like
energy is very finite in my body in my
human little body it is not gonna be
here forever it will only last to the
day it's supposed to last so I'm very
conscious of how I use my energy keeping
in mind the goals that
we have you know especially with a small
business like we're just two people it's
just us so like I don't know I just
don't I really just think secession
would be a really good answer and
everyone should live their truths and
then I'm very I think we should build a
wall between California and the rest of
the country and I think we should let
everyone live the life that they say
will be best and let's see where we're
at in 10-15 years lean this way so I'm
like not in the show I guarantee you
[ __ ] is gonna be running a [ __ ] muck
on the other side of that wall where
they're still having conversations from
the 1960s did you not watch Black
Panther we cannot wall ourselves off and
not help the other people we can't hold
our resources sure we can okay and that
is it forever in liberal that's the
cycle that liberals have gotten
themselves into they also you are way
too optimistic about California oh I
know I'm just trying to prove a point at
this point it's like let me just show
you the comparison slice like the split
screen of like this is what's happening
in California where we're like trying to
I don't know do universal like income
yeah and this is where we are I'm not
going to name a state but you already
know let's just call it Florida and like
you know like high schoolers and college
students are like really struggling to
even find like a legal abortion clinic
and like let's see how that plays out
over a 10 or 15 years I guarantee you
the result is not good cuz we've already
been here so that's my binary solution
for world domination I don't foresee
that happening of course not no one's
gonna listen
I do
sign me up I don't know what the answer
is I think even I can't remember the
name of the paradox it's like when you
know very little about something you
have a lot of overconfidence about your
cooter yes I think I live in that space
where I know just enough to know I don't
know anything and it's like a really
humbling space to live in
or like everybody around me is very
smart I'm just like going through the
world being like damn this is really
complicated like these these questions
yeah yeah if you're polar opposites I've
never heard a more polar I'll say every
way and I say you just makes Cortney
Darcis value your mind trying to figure
out the solution but I do side more with
Dora on that because because I am but I
do side with you I'm trying to figure
out the solution yeah but by going so
analytical of the whole world
I'm just like this is too complicated it
probably isn't solved as easily as
saying California is more progressive so
let's do the California thing what's are
some ways and some complications that
can be eliminated faster than others
it's gonna leave it about Ron what do
you think dark Dara's a little MLK and
Courtney's a little Malcolm X at the
risk of getting myself in trouble she's
officially to Malcolm X okay because in
this situation yes I see how you could
make that division cuz you're just like
[ __ ] let's get out of here which
actually makes you more like Marcus
Garvey but let's not split hairs but
like when you talk about like going to
Berkeley and doing all this work and
like how do we figure out all the stuff
I very much am like y'all figure that
[ __ ] out you know let me know when you
got it because I'm over here trying to
live and like if you're talking about
Maslow's hierarchy like part of getting
like you're trying to get people to see
illogical you have to have clean water
to drink and this is the United States
and there are plenty of people who don't
you have to like not have lead paint in
almost all of the walls in Philadelphia
that is actually stopping kids from
having successful neurological
development in poor neighborhoods
beautiful mural painted under an
underpass with a homeless person just
sleeping right underneath it and I'm
like y'all city guess what you can
beautify this underpass as much as you
want but I will never not see the human
being that doesn't have a home or roof
over their head there's no amount of
paint right that's gonna beautify that
right and so in many situations I'm very
much like as a black person and as a
woman there's so much emotional labor
expected of me and I'm not [ __ ] doing
it like if I have a choice I won't do it
like even at work I am a digital
marketer my job is to market things
digitally
but when it's time for lunch to arrive
who needs to greet the people like when
it's time to answer the door when it
like just like the little things that
you do to take care and make sure
everything is going smoothly in the
world
that's like women's work I'm hugging
over it so even though I do it a lot of
times and that's on me when there's
other situations where I feel like I'm
not gonna take it on I'm not gonna do it
sometimes when you don't do something
people see that as an action or move
girl
yeah that's the emotional labor where
everyone can read into you and even if
you are just standing still and trying
to remove yourself from a situation
that's you've got an attitude you do in
all times you doing the most you what
you don't want to it's a lot it's a lot
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
like you just being alive in the world
and people throwing their projections on
you all day so let's let's let's revisit
this one more time let's also see this
as not only this competence and this
economic climate let's also see it as
the Maslow's hierarchy of needs so if
the bottom physiological needs if those
if those base physiological needs are
not being met across the world not even
just the US but the world in all these
different places then it's that in
itself impedes the ability for creative
development for for trying to make an
impact in the world because then we're
focused on the meal or the clean water
or shelter with all that and so that
seems to be this first I think most
humane point of where we can start with
the conversation and it's not to say
immediately just go and start funneling
wealth down the income hierarchy so that
way it can be provided to people saying
that it well literacy yeah yeah let's
unpack this because I think we're we're
about to get to a point of
AI and robotics that is going to kind of
put us into a tipping point of you bi
and the universal basic income and there
should be some sort of literacy
associated with you know you are being
given twelve hundred dollars a month now
and you appropriate maybe 75% of that
for rent maybe fifteen percent of that
for food so exactly so it's tough
because though that number was very San
Francisco asked versus a rate that
should be a factor as well where are you
aiming and what are the housing cost and
so yes so this is this multivariate
conversation but the first and foremost
thing and it seems to be would you guys
agree to this I asked this question that
your life outcome being associated with
your zip code in familiar with the
literature right I've heard of this
theory explain it a little bit just that
if you're born in Pacific Heights in San
Francisco you are much more likely to
end up being like your parents that
owned a house in Pacific Heights etc
versus if you're born in a zip code
where there's 700 homicides
oh yeah yeah I'm sure everyone is
renting so no you probably yeah things
like that that like that so and so then
you think about what's going on in that
in that you know for the base
physiological needs for the person
impact Heights versus the person in
South Side Chicago and you can literally
immerse yourself in the shoes of what it
would be like to be each one of those
people and then to say say are the
opportunities really equitable are they
the answer is clearly no and so we're
not saying we're not saying equal
outcomes for everybody we're saying
equal opportunities for people and how
do we actually get there and so so so
just unpacking that that that basic
physiological physical needs and this
roll of the dice so that's well that's
just how I compare to roll the dice if
you're if your dice are rolled and you
end up in Southside Chicago versus your
dice rolled you end up in pack heights
that is a significant life outcome
different
if we truly believe in a roll of the
dice and humanity in general how can we
decide to purchase a third boat instead
of go and try and hire 50 people to
solve a problem in the world and so
that's kind of this this conversation
I've been trying to have on the show and
I just like to maybe hear your thoughts
this roll the dice how could you not try
and solve these basic physiological
needs for other people on this planet
shouldn't it be a fire under all of our
asses are they just not spiritually
enlightened enough to get that what's
what's what's going on again we've
talked about like this vested interest
in keeping your idea of the world safe
and I think there's not a fire because
people don't believe it like it's it's
the reason that we still have to fund
studies to say if you're born in certain
zip code you're gonna have like poor
life outcomes because people are still
like yeah exactly it's it's again it's
because if you believe in this myth of
hard work than people who are
impoverished are at fault and you have
to break that idea before you get people
motivated to do anything and and and
that's that's hard and it's true across
the board I mean like that idea and
lives in my head somewhere it's still
back there and something I have to
actively think about talk about and
fight against because we all have these
biases you know a well socialized person
as a person who learns to norm of their
societies right those are our norms
that's what we've been taught that's how
we function in the world so it's hard to
like I don't know take the red pill or
whatever like look back and see how
things are actually going on
design matrix yeah yeah I you know and I
don't have the answer on a global level
because I know for myself it was
something that I was made very aware of
the role of the dice if you will it was
not something that I was fully aware of
until I got to college until I
understood just how different people's
dice could land but then mixing that
with knowing that my parents we don't
come from generational wealth because my
family is directly descended from slaves
we were coming from Florida so my family
but you know Louisiana in taxes like
slave trade happened right there and so
you know coming from a house where it
was a two-parent household you know
parents stayed married till death did
them part and I I had an education
because they said to me you will you can
go to college or you can get a job and
go to college and those are your options
after you turn 18 so when you have that
mindset you know being drilled into you
from about the age of six
it's a privilege it's truly a privilege
I love the way that I was raised and you
have to go out to the world and really
come to terms with that especially as a
black person as a black woman I could be
the exact same person that I am same
looks have the same ideas but if I were
living on any other side of this world
right now my circumstances could it be
vastly different just like that we
haven't even talked about pretty
privileged honey pretty privileged is
like the best privilege of life but just
the basic privilege to have a roof over
my head like I said college education I
I was the one that propositioned my dad
to like get me SAT courses because I was
scheming and I was like if you invest in
this then I'll get a scholarship and
then we don't have to pay for college
and then your money will like pay for
itself and it happened that's a
privilege so my goal now is recognized
machinations work to know that I have
the action of an SAT Chander I wasn't
told we can't afford that they were told
do you have a recommendation I was like
sure I'll just go back to my private
school where they're all getting SAT
tutors and just had one of them come
teach me it was that simple and I
recognized every single day that people
that are just like me do not have that
privilege and it's systemic why they
don't have that privilege I was the only
brown face I was still the only brown
face when I go into meetings it's I was
just at like a bunch of meetings last
week and I was like are y'all serious
right now like I'm really the only black
woman in this room black person and I do
just have a vested interest in
mentorship like that is the that is the
thing I have found lacking in my life
that is the thing that I think we should
be giving back you have to like each one
reach one each month because that's the
only thing you can take responsibility
for each one reach one teach one because
that is the only thing that we have
actual control over we can talk about
Gen Z till the cows come home but until
you are actually sitting there talking
to one and hearing what their experience
is like in this school system that
they're living in now you don't know
anything about that generation do not
presume from a news article that got it
so wrong with every other generation to
know you know yeah and I think you're
inspiring you can do it tell them and
teach them and teach them the importance
of teaching the generation that comes
after them all of the tricks and all of
the slip-ups that have come so that we
don't end up villainizing each other and
trying to continually blame one another
for the state of the world because we're
all unless you're under 18 and you
haven't had a chance to vote yet we're
all responsible so yeah and what you
talking about like going to the private
school knowing that an SAT tutor is a
thing like I think setting expectations
it's like sort of more of an ephemeral
idea than like having food or having
water and the other things that we've
been talking about but the fact that our
parents
when we are I don't know five six years
old are like what college are you going
to go to they're putting it in our head
not are you going to go to college like
that level of expectation setting of
forming your world and what the
possibilities are for your world is so
important yeah and and so I think I
don't again I don't know how to solve
that beyond actually exposing people to
more the other thing that I would say on
a super practical basis we're talking
about policy stuff public schools are
funded by real estate taxes and that's
bananas
because if you live in a poor area where
people have homes that are less
expensive so they don't pay as much
taxes less money is going to the schools
Wow and then I think about a city like
San Francisco where our real estate
taxes should be off the Richter so that
means that our education system for
public students should be director as
well it should be in it it's spoiler
alert it's better than in some other
places for sure is so well in this
country for education it's yes sane but
also that's not an accident like this
stuff doesn't have an accident like the
fact that the Texas is so huge so they
buy all these textbooks so they get to
literally write history and so they get
to start calling slaves migrant workers
like that's really happening and you're
really like like you're really going to
my heart like I lived with a young lady
who this is after college was talking to
me about the War of Northern Aggression
and I was like what and she can refer to
the Civil War she is referring to the
Civil War as the War of Northern
Aggression why she grew up in
a Carolina I don't want to get too
simple
remember and that's what she was taught
and I remember literally like oh yeah
it's a hole that's that's a window into
her life yes guys and this is a black
woman and imagine if you learned about
the Civil War from the perspective of it
was the north and they were just being
aggressive yeah that's crazy because you
who's crazy aggressive like southern
plantation oh I mean you know kind of
going all over the place but like again
it's like it's about how you frame these
conversations and these stories from a
very young age yeah and I don't know I I
feel like it's like a typical like
progressive black person doing like read
a book but the author is like don't just
read a book read who's writing the book
learn where their perspective is coming
from that everything has been framed
this is again going back to Lake but
that's the kind of education that you
get when teachers are like able to take
a step back and really think about like
we're gonna talk today about media
literacy like yeah it's a private school
education yeah cuz it's all funded and
everyone's paying for their own bucks
so so but then I think it's fair to say
that then after we get to this basic
physiological needs level that's met the
next level that's pretty much the
responsibility of the parent to have
been literate enough to have decided to
have a child only when they were ready
to be able to meet that child's basic
needs and then after that then you have
to anticipate that they ever will be
ready right cuz I think I can wait to
have children because I anticipate a
time in my life where I will be in a
financial position to make that a wise
decision right but if there's no light
at the end of my tunnel then what's
stopping me from having a kid when I'm
20 versus when I'm 30 yeah sorry
that's it's very important so then as we
get to that basic need is met then I
think above that I think
safe to say that is this whole literacy
of how to be a parent and how to foster
a community for a child how to teach
that child into the world it seems to be
controversial to tell people how to be
an adult how to be a parent to a child
right it seems to be a very
controversial thing but at the same time
it is very important for a parent to not
be teaching their child that the earth
is flat right these are just very
important things to be communicate for
example we've moved on from these this
is not Northern Aggression this is not
this is not how we talk about history
and so and so that's why this is not a
subjective way to explain what has
occurred in the world this is a very
objective there's lots and lots of
evidence in one in the one direction so
we've said it is objective now and so
because of that if a parent is well
educated enough to be able to teach
their child about these basic
understandings of the world the cosmos
the evolution their consciousness their
body their heart their mind the way that
we've evolved from monkeys through
culture into where we are today if we
can at least at least get to that point
together and then to say please be
open-minded and loving and caring and
gentle and get into longer in more
nuanced conversations with people when
you're older and you know inspire them
to to make something of their life past
just eating and drinking food and stuff
like that I think that that can be we
talk about this a lot we talk about what
are those kind of couple principles that
a parent can make sure that they try and
bring their child up with into the world
i I agree with that in part I do think
though for a large portion of the
country especially with like black and
brown people they are living in that
space where there is food insecurity
where they don't have the things that
you talked about but they still can be
effective parents and I would sort of
hazard us not to go into a place that
like can get inadvertently classist if
we are saying it's not until you reach
this level of financial security that
you can then teach your children these
things because the reality is there are
smart people everywhere and there are
really capable parents who are teaching
their kids the right things in the hood
yep
yeah that's definitely happening that's
a very common tale yeah that's a really
good point every single area no matter
what socioeconomic status or
demographics on the planet is going to
have a kind of slightly different way to
up bring a child then in those different
principles that they'll be teaching the
child but then these sort of basic
fundamental truths I think are really
crucial for the child to really get I
mean that's a fair assumption for people
that are making policies that impact
whether or not people have access to
certain resources to consider exactly
what you're talking about
odds are if somebody has their needs met
they will be able to parent
well responsibly and bring out another
productive member of society I think
it's a fair assumption that you know
anyone doing public policy that impacts
people like that should keep in mind I
mean for sure we should be making
everybody's life easier and this idea
that like life is hard and it should be
like I take exception to that
yeah I hate that idea because I want to
go relax at a beach or a park I don't
want to have to worry about where my
next food comes from how do we build a
world where the kids can relax and not
have to worry about where the food comes
from well and that's the the concern
that I have with universal basic income
I think it would be great I would love
to live in the world where that were the
case people will still be creative
they'll still do things in the world
they'll be more creative and think so
yeah that's cool there's a level of
again like creative output takes energy
where do you think the new bi should
come from how do you mean like sue
should fund it
yeah where does the ubi come from I
don't know the answer to that okay I
would assume from somewhere in our
government we can fund it there's
there's a bunch of different proposals
that are out right now we've had a bunch
on the show but okay it's so that's an
important so that's an important the
whole system has to change
that's dollars in Sanson one sense of
value is important what something is
worth right you know you mentioned early
but Millennials aren't buying down
diamonds anymore good I don't understand
yeah value of a diamond it's a
hallucination it's a global
hallucination there's many things like
that that are global hallucinations but
I also think like if you look in places
that have systems that are even
approaching that like everybody likes to
hold up Sweden and like there's there's
other things that are a part of it like
the transportation doesn't cost as much
or anything like the health care is
taking care like there's things that
make a place ready for universal basic
income and I think we don't have those
things we also have three hundred and
fifteen or twenty now million people
which is a lot more than five yeah
making it really do make sense to do
this it gives us a really powerful army
and it makes getting everything else
done a lot harder I love you too so much
I want you back there's so much less to
talk about talk about human nature next
cuz I think all of this would inform our
opinions on where we think human nature
should be and where we think it is yeah
that's just each one to unpack Justin we
you know I left talking about evolution
yeah two pretty nerdy girls I think I'm
more nerdy than you but it's definitely
oh my god he taught me about ghouls
yeah that's like tech nerdy stuff but
you are amazing thank you so much for
coming on to the show we have a lot to
unpack in our next time I know I'm
excited for it yeah thank you for
joining us yeah yes
Courtney Thomas Darin Wilson thank you
so much for next big thing the upcoming
shows on the 28th you know today ask him
at least one simulation question just
one just one what do you two think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
Oh flowers I think they're evidence that
God is real Hey gerrae
that was I like paralyzed by how quickly
you answered the most beautiful thing in
the world I think is love I don't think
you can see it anything that makes me
cry on a television show
oh that's was the most beautiful thing
in the world like when you watch the
Great British Bake Off I finish my
muffins early can I help you and I'm
like that's emotional manipulation oh my
god I'm talking about Extreme Makeover
Home Edition battle community coming
together to build a whole straight guys
that one gets everybody except for that
one episode which anyway so this is
turned into television the most
beautiful thing in the world
I like how both of you had a addition to
what the word was so with people come on
and say love her flowers right but they
don't give the addition and the addition
for you was that his evidence that is
real and for you it was
for you it was because you can't see it
yeah I like that a lot you can't see it
and so these what exists outside of the
three-dimensional flesh vehicle reality
that we live in is a fascinating we
talked about on the show a lot I'm glad
that wrong prompted us to do at least
one we have a hundred more questions be
sure to plug their show as well as our
viewers to go check out - yes we just
did yeah the 28th yeah piano fight at
5:30 on Saturday if you want those
details you can follow us at and BT the
show I am also producing two shows this
weekend
they are comedy storytelling shows and
you can follow me at Darin and Wilson if
you want details on that and you should
come to the shows I will be at the show
and you can follow me at its Olivia DOE
and just check us out on YouTube just
hit the search bar and type in next big
thing with Kourtney and Berra boom I
love it
thank you so much again thanks everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time remember to share this content with
other people give us a like comment to
subscribe if you're not subscribed yet
smash that subscribe button go to their
channel smash the subscribe button ok
all right how about we gently drop a
feather on the subscribe
drop a snowflake on the thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you join us on patreon as
well help us keep this a studio
sustainable we would love that and
appreciate it so much on so tomorrow
thanks for tuning in peace out
[Music]